congratulations on receiving that offer
letter but don't accept it just yet
because this is an opportunity to have a
significant impact on your long-term
earning potential I'm going to share my
top five suggestions on how to negotiate
your job offer to secure a better
outcome for yourself
one
don't negotiate a single issue think
about this it's not just your salary you
should be discussing rather it's the
total compensation package
what are the issues in addition to
compensation that you value
stock options vacation days signing
bonuses lab space or even work
flexibility offer multiple solution
options all of which you'd be happy to
accept
you don't want to frame your ask as a
simple yes or no
offering options gives you control while
also leaving room for the hiring company
to provide input on what they can and
cannot give
two do your research
find compensation information for
similar positions but also reach out to
your network and friends in gathering
useful information identify what holes
exist in your preparation
prepare questions that you can use in
your negotiation but intersperse the
questions to which you need the answers
with questions to which you already know
the answers it helps to use questioning
strategically
[Music]
three have solid alternatives
alternatives are your safety net not a
standard by which you judge the
acceptability of a deal don't start a
negotiation by saying or thinking
anything above this is good you should
set an aspiration what you might get if
everything went your way
and the better your Alternatives the
more comfortable you are with walking
away the more comfortable you are with
walking away the higher the premium your
counterpart will have to pay to keep you
in this negotiation so understand the
power that a willingness to walk away
creates for you
four
know what you want
know the minimum you are willing to
accept and honor that level on the other
end know your dream scenario an
optimistic assessment of what you could
get in this deal expectations Drive our
Behavior so shoot for this aspiration
you will likely come out with more than
if you're merely trying to do better
than your alternative
and five know what your counterpart
wants
good negotiations solve problems they
don't establish a winner and a loser
how will what you're asking for benefit
your counterpart
present your proposals as solutions to
problems that they have
and there you have it those are my top
five tips for negotiating a job offer
now go out there and get more of what it
is you want
[Music]